bom é
noite meu nome é bn é nos últimos dois
anos eu sou mais conhecido como sócio da
paola não tem mais nome próprio mas já
tive um dia é normalmente quando eu falo
a gente eu converso muito sobre
empreendedorismo sobre desafios de
crescimento enfim sobre negócios
mas conversando com o pessoal da
organização e vendo um pouco o line up
deste evento a gente enfim eu decidi
pegar um outro caminho outro approach
falar um pouco r justamente dos impactos
que a restauração pode ter na sociedade
eu gosto muito dessa palavra restauração
mas o que a gastronomia enfim porque
conta um pouco também da da origem do
restaurante neh nah no século 18 quando
tinham os estaleiros os tabus que a
pessoa pagava pra dormir pra deixar o
cavalo é esses lugares faziam uns caldos
também nos caldos bem encorpados com
bastante legume ou só para de carne e
serviam esses cálculos como um brinde em
casa ela pagava pra ficar e ganhava se
esse caldo que era um caldo restaurador
em algum momento é esses lugares
começarão a oferecer o caldo e vender
esse caldo como um produto e aí surgiram
os primeiros restaurantes e daí vem a
palavra restauração que muito pouca
gente usa que o mercado usa a
gastronomia é antes de mim muito de
entrar um pouco eu gosto de enfim falar
um pouco que é um restaurante no final
das contas nem e simplificar um pouco o
que é um restaurante no fundo se a gente
for pensar é um lugar que pega um monte
de ingredientes e legumes verduras carne
sal leite farinha e jô
enfim cogumelo e aí pega esses
ingredientes acaba o gás luz água
pessoas utensílios e sai do outro lado
um prato de uma maneira muito simples
isso acontece em um restaurante não é
tão simples assim como vocês puderam ver
aqui na operação do crepe é não é tão
fácil quanto parece
mas simplificando é a linha é um pouco
isso né
é óbvio que os desafios são muitos
hoje em dia muito mais do que oferecer
um prato é os restaurantes ou qualquer
tipo de ambiente a gente eu tenho um
restaurante em um café tem que entregar
uma experiência né
e fazer isso acontecer vai conseguir
entregar o prato com qualidade e
conseguir entregar uma experiência
bacana
no momento que a gente está hoje com
todos os problemas de todos afirma que
todos os empreendedores de todos os
ramos acabam tendo é algo bem complexo
é bom é e na verdade não é tão fácil
néné conseguir chegar à final do mês e
pagar as contas já é um enorme desafio
de qualquer empreendedor ainda mais no
ramo de restauração onde a gente tem
milhares de concorrentes é é um monte de
gente novo ano um monte de coisa abrindo
eo monte dificuldade na cadeia
e aí então simples ato como transformar
os ingredientes em um prato
se a gente for pensar quantas pessoas
serão impactadas nisso
então a gente tem os chamados
stakeholders
a gente tem todo o nosso fornecedor
quanto são 16 pegar um quilo simples
carne frango porco e cordeiro a gente
tudo separado peixes e frutos do mar
peixes e frutos do mar são separados a
gente tem pelo menos uns dois três
fornecedores de secos e molhados ovo
laticínio bebida alcoólica bebida não
alcoólica então os setores de bebidas e
aí a gente chega lá em 10 12 9 são
pequenas se a gente for considerar que
tem dez pessoas trabalhando indicaram
uma dessas empresas estão 127 foi
considerar que tem 45 pessoas na família
de cada um já são 600 pessoas só em
fornecedores mas os nossos clientes
passam média será de esperar uma média
de um lugar desde 2000 três mil pessoas
por mês
aí a gente te
as concessionárias todas apeadas gás que
já são mais uma cacetada de pessoas que
estão envolvidas nesse processo
nossas funcionárias restaurante muito
muito muito muito muito pequeno tipo
quilo da esquina deve ter oito pessoas
trabalhando vezes quatro vezes cinco são
mais 40
as entidades de classe gestão de
resíduos no meio ambiente a gente está
falando de mais ou menos fila umas 50 60
70 mil pessoas por ano que são
impactadas
de certa forma nessa cadeia de da
restauração e é muito interessante como
se a gente foi com consigo
se a gente fizer um exercício forte como
a gente consegue impactar cada um desses
pontos dessa cadeia positivamente
vou dar um exemplo muito simples do que
foi feito um dos nossos restaurantes é
dentre os fornecedores um belo dia ela
chegou pra mim foi um dos dois anos e
falou eu queria que lá nos aflitos teve
somente uma bola vermelha na verdade o
problema somente produtos somente
produtos orgânicos não é principalmente
produtos orgânicos
quando a gente fala de orgânico é no
brasil inteiro a gente tem dois grandes
desafios são do preço que é uma outra
discussão se deveria ser tão cara assim
isso é justificável que seja tão mais
caro o acesso e aquilo que eu falo
acesso não é ter acesso aos orgânicos
isso existisse mas foi o mercado tem
aliciado hora muito simples os
produtores são muito pequenos o problema
você tem acesso
mesmo respeitando a sazonalidade porque
em que ingredientes orgânicos são
sazonais por exemplo é impossível
o tomate de janeiro até agora 11 saio
sem agrotóxico epe o volume para servir
no restaurante não adianta você falar eu
tenho que ouvir quando 75 quilos não
adianta cinco pratos e seis pratos e
precisa ter pelo menos 50 então
conseguia se fornecimento volume é um
desafio muito grande muito bem a gente
tinha lá os anti estabelecida que estava
roubando está funcionando estava tudo
certinho os fornecedores entregavam tudo
redondinho deixava rentabilidade no
final do mês os funcionários eram pagos
a gente pagava imposto foi bom então
vamos comprar essa briga nessa época
tinha um cara
aqui em são paulo fazendo e conseguindo
entregar não é legal não é um cara legal
até hoje ele está no mercado ea gente
resolveu ir atrás de outras opções
então gente conhecia o pessoal do
greenpeace ea gente chamou ele para
fazer uma expedição de campo ea gente
perguntou será que não tem ninguém na
cidade de são paulo fazendo tanto
orgânico e quando falo pantanal orgânico
eu não vou muito longe em certificação e
bd mas o simples fato de botar alguma
coisa uma semente no chão faz é somente
crescer sem jogar o top 5 que já é muito
complexo e aí com eles a gente
identificou dois caras
o primeiro é um projeto sensacional na
na zona leste chamada cidade sem fome do
hans é e em um projeto muito legal na
verdade ele pega ele pegar é de onde
passar fio elétrico em cima ou tajra em
baixo na zona leste tem muito porque é o
que sobe da serra
ele pega a concessão desses terrenos
porque não se pode construir nada faz
umas hortas orgânicas ensina comunidade
a plantar e cuidar dessas hortas ea com
própria comunidade se reabastece com
esses produtos e obviamente tem uma
sobra bem grande que a gente poderia
aproveitar o segundo projeto que a gente
conheceu o pessoal de parelheiros também
dentro da cidade de são paulo é que tem
não sei se vocês sabem mas se vocês vão
ali na abaixo do teotônio o negócio
fantástico assim tem milhares e milhares
e milhares de pessoas plantando e
colhendo coisas incríveis com água limpa
é uma cooperativa chama cooper apas que
lidera pelo arpa de que faz justamente
essa coleta entre todas essas famílias e
auxilia na venda desses produtos ea
gente foi lá e conhecer esses caras
obviamente muito desorganizados e
começamos a conversar bater um papo e aí
a gente tomou decisão foram beleza vamos
substituir dof para dentro do
restaurante vamos organizar um pouco
nosso restaurante trabalhar com esses
caras
por um ano a gente ficou estruturando
essa acabei gastando muito dinheiro
muito além do que a gente deveria andou
do que normal aumentando muito custo o
restaurante o curso de pessoas para
poder receber visitas organizadas em
estragados e pediu fácil ea beterraba se
pedia beterraba linha que a água se não
pedia que a bolinha que a água se pedia
que eu ouvia convive há 69 reais o quilo
a eles mandavam a nota não faturar do
sistema tinha que ligar pra ele falar
que tal pelo mercado foi um ano disso
mas depois de um ano com todos os
aprendizados o cara conseguiu se
estruturar o que é muito legal conseguir
estruturar hoje atende outros
restaurantes ele tem uma produtividade
maior ele entende mais do que os
restaurantes precisam é e ensina os
fazendeiros lá o pessoal que está aqui
estava plantando na hora não planta
sei lá abobrinha porque o pessoal não
gosta muito de abobrinha caipira com
plantava abobrinha italiana por ser
bonita é mais legal e também está tudo
certo ea gente consegue vender mais
olha o plantar tomate agora que o tomate
é bom então a gente conseguiu criar toda
uma cadeia de produção nova na cidade de
são paulo
através desse trabalho é intenso
desenvolveu o pessoal da cooper atas
outro exemplo bacana que a gente fez é
do lixo 1
não sei se vocês sabem mas o lixo a
prova no lugar né
está ali nosso amigo que também ajuda
com isso é o show ele é dividido em três
categorias e ciclável rejeito e orgânico
normalmente um estabelecimento comercial
deveria deveria porque muitos muitos
muitos não fazem pagar uma empresa
privada para recolher esse lixo nos
restaurantes nem sempre esse co
o lixo então sei lá de 30 sacos que a
gente produz um dia aos 45 são
reciclados ea gente guardava uma
cooperativa retirar e os outros 25 e um
problema até que a gente conheceu uma
menina chamada fernanda que tem um
instituto chamado situando que começou a
fazer um trabalho de pegar o lixo
orgânico apostar
então ela é esse lixo entrava ela
separar o lixo e compostáveis gravado br
votava pr ela dava umas moedinhas ea
gente fez um trabalho muito bacana
abraçou isso por um alguns treinamentos
no restaurante colocando o lixo especial
investiram em cadeia e se tivermos que
mudar um pouco o depósito porque
diferentemente da da da outra empresa
recolher o lixo onde é capaz de recolher
todo dia e por três meses que o tempo a
gente conseguiu fazer esse projeto
funcionar
dos 30 sacos de lixo cinco anos
recicláveis 22 eram compostados eram
orgânico só três viravam do jeito que é
uma quantidade muito impressionante é
infelizmente a legislação que já era
ruim agora com a entrada da gestão ou
não funcionando eles
ela foi notificada teve que parar de
fazer isso porque você não pode recolher
lixos em um caminhão que comprime e está
a comportar-se não pode comprimir tem
uma cena uma etapa de seleção então ela
teve que parar mas a gente está pronto
para voltar esperando ela a ela se
organizar ea gestão nova também se mexer
um pouco em relação a isso e aí tem
outras diz que a gente faz né o gestão
atividade cada ser humano a gente tem
130 funcionários todos eles muito bem
tratados muito bem cuidados com o plano
de carreira
a gente utiliza painel solar em alguns
dos restaurantes que em tecnologia no
caso dos restaurantes difícil de ter um
retorno
diferentemente do led led nos últimos
três anos g20 concentre um retorno
melhor graças à dilma também que eu
então conta de luz então fica mais fácil
é a parte de gestão de recursos hídricos
nos luta há dez anos a gente teve um
problema muito sério de água na cidade
de são paulo e reeducar todos nós
funcionários há como utilizar melhor a
água e de certa forma a gente acaba
afetando também o jeito e utilizava na
casa dele é muito bacana mas o que eu
quero é chegar é assim porque a gente
faz isso
fazemos isso porque faz parte da minha
ideologia e biologia da paula é eu vim
do terceiro setor e comecei a trabalhar
no terceiro setor então devolver de
certa forma para a sociedade é algo que
faz parte da minha ideologia fosse
pessoa mas eu entendo o dom é que a
grande maioria dos empresários
sobreviver no final do mês é muito
complicado muito complexo
consegui ter um lucrinho ali no final do
mês que é importante nunca é importante
sem lucro não tem negócio nem de impacto
social ser lucro para poder sustentar
essa é a sociedade teve é é muito
difícil para levantar a cabeça para
conseguir pensar né e essa realidade mas
tem um agente muito muito forte de
mudança que consegue puxar todas e isso
é muito importante
isso isso é o que eu quero chegar para a
gente poder conversar
não quero falar que os demais eu sou
bonzinho mas muito pelo contrário tem
uma tem uma parte dessa cabeça e
consegue puxar tudo isso e toda essa
mudança que essa mudança começa a ser
mais valorizada e começa a transformar
todo o mercado que são vocês né
é pergunta simples dentro de um ano
antes quantos de vocês foi um
restaurante nos últimos dez dias
agora imagina se você entrar se
necessário que vocês foram na hora de
sentar se na mesa se falavam como legal
essa ou colocar nem kaká é um exemplo
estão em feliz hoje ilegal a folha de
alfaro é que é legal essa batata onde
ela vem ela vem do ciesp atacar mas o
cara do ceagesp comprar onde ela tá aqui
no brasil ela vem da argentina do vietnã
camboja e que você faz com ela
conquistou a vão lavar com a que você
faz para depois que o celular você joga
fora
sei lá tem água corrente ser lavado em
uma pia e descasque as batatas com casca
seja lá fora e para onde vai
lixo é então são perguntas muito simples
que promete o cara não quer saber de
responder muito provavelmente e que
também não é culpa dele porque o cara
nunca pensou que ele teria que responder
isso agora tem que responder onde vem a
carne todo mundo responde essa caneta de
gol mas essas são perguntas muito
simples que mudam
é toda uma dinâmica porque esses essas
perguntas começaram a ser feitas com
mais volume né
o canal só eu preciso começar ainda
responder
e aí vai começar a responder coisas não
estão legais ele só po tenta agora pra
eu ter lucro e vou ter que conseguir
fazer essas coisas funcionarem então
inverte toda uma cadeia né eu acho que o
tempo estava estourado com questão do
microfone mas o que eu queria falar são
dois pontos
uma coisa muito simples como restaurante
consegue ter um impacto muito grande na
sociedade e na cidade que a gente vive e
vocês como clientes são a gente dessa
mudança com coisas muito simples com
questionamentos muito fáceis de serem
feitos
então faça uma pergunta e procurem saber
valorizem quem faz e ajudem também quem
não faz a fazer um pouco melhor
procurando indicando que você precisa
tá bom é isso pessoal
[Aplausos]